From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Zoe Chace. Ira is away this week. He's actually doing a dance performance in Australia. So I'm hosting the show, and it happens that this week's show is about something I am not very good at-- getting your money's worth.
来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是佐伊·蔡斯。艾拉这周不在，他去澳大利亚进行舞蹈表演了。所以这周由我来主持节目，碰巧这周节目的主题是我不太擅长的事情——物有所值。
This is something I know about myself. I am bad at saving money. I don't haggle. I never comparison shop. It's been an especially acute problem for me because I used to report on economics, and so I'm aware that, in economics terms, I am wildly inefficient with my money. I waste it. I am not good with it, and I've been trying to get better for years.
这是我对自己的一点了解。我不擅长省钱。我不砍价，从不货比三家。这对我是个特别严重的问题，因为我曾经报道经济学，所以我很清楚，从经济学角度看，我在金钱方面极其低效。我挥霍它。我不善理财，多年来我一直试图改进。
My friend Jacob Goldstein, on the other hand, is a master. We worked on the Planet Money podcast together. Jacob's ability to navigate spending is impressive. He just always seems like an expert in this area of life.
另一方面，我的朋友雅各布·戈尔茨坦是个高手。我们曾在《金钱星球》播客一起工作。雅各布驾驭消费的能力令人印象深刻。在这个生活领域，他似乎总是个专家。
We're at a grocery store. I came with Jacob both because I needed food, and I wanted to watch how he shops, how he spends his money. Going through the aisles, Jacob talks like we're on a trading floor. He uses the word commodity for the basic food staples, which is fair. It's just technical.
我们在一家杂货店。我和雅各布一起来，既是因为我需要买食物，也是因为我想观察他是如何购物的，如何花钱的。走在过道里，雅各布说话的方式就像我们在交易大厅一样。他用“商品”这个词来形容基本的主食，这很公平，只是比较专业。
He has an idea about a reasonable price for each item based on a running catalog in his head of what those items cost at nearby stores and online-- the market. Organic baby carrots, $2 a pound. Bananas, $0.79 a bunch. This is a reference price.
他心里有一个参考目录，根据附近商店和网上的价格——也就是市场价——对每件商品有一个合理的心理价位。有机小胡萝卜，每磅2美元。香蕉，一串0.79美元。这就是参考价格。
So like commodity cheddar cheese-- $5 a pound is my reference price. For sharp cheese-- that's $8.50 a pound. No.
比如普通切达干酪，每磅5美元是我的参考价格。如果是精选切达干酪，那是每磅8.5美元。不。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊。
Not for-- that's not a-- no. It was too expensive. It's just commodity cheddar cheese, which I know I can get for $5 a pound at my grocery store.
不值——那不是——不。这太贵了。它只是普通的切达干酪，我知道在我的杂货店每磅5美元就能买到。
If there's not an obvious way to measure what the best price is, for my friend, it's a little maddening. It's an unsolvable puzzle.
对于我的朋友来说，如果没有明显的方法来衡量什么是最好的价格，那就有点令人抓狂。这是一个无法解开的谜题。
Paper towels are complicated. They make it hard to compare because they're different size rolls. This says 6 huge equals 15 regular. And then this says 8 giant equals 12 regular.
纸巾很复杂。因为卷的大小不同，很难比较。这一包上写着6大卷等于15个普通卷。那一包写着8巨卷等于12个普通卷。
So clearly it's not the same math? And they don't have any that are regular, so it's really hard to compare. It's like buying mattresses or something.
所以很明显数学不一样？而且他们没有卖普通装的，所以真的很难比较。这就像买床垫什么的。
I'm going to buy this coffee purely because it says New Orleans.
我要买这款咖啡，纯粹是因为上面写着“新奥尔良”。
You like chicory? I'm going to guess it's going to have like that chicory flavor.
你喜欢菊苣咖啡吗？我猜它会有那种菊苣的味道。
When I'm in a grocery store, I choose the canned tomatoes that look the most authentically Italian. I pick the olive oil with the fancy name, which, in front of Jacob, I find embarrassing, obviously.
在杂货店时，我会选择看起来最正宗的意大利罐装西红柿。我会挑选名字听起来高级的橄榄油，显然，在雅各布面前这样做让我感到尴尬。
So regarding coffee, I go like middle. So this is $10 a pound. Expensive coffee is $20 a pound. So we go through about a pound of coffee a week, so that's like $500 a year difference.
关于咖啡，我选中间档。这个每磅10美元。昂贵的咖啡每磅20美元。我们每周大约喝掉一磅咖啡，一年下来就是500美元的差价。
And how often are you annualizing costs?
你多久会把成本折算成年度开支一次？
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
Just tell me.
直接告诉我吧。
That question is almost mean.
这个问题简直有点刻薄。
That question is almost mean, he says. That I did not expect-- that he would think I was being mean. I was impressed. Taking your friend to the grocery store, it's like showering with them. Both of you get really vulnerable.
他说这个问题简直刻薄。我没想到他会认为我说话刻薄。我当时很佩服他。带朋友去杂货店，就像和他们一起洗澡一样。你们双方都变得非常脆弱。
Like, he's good at this. I'm bad at this. Why is he embarrassed?
你看，他很擅长这个。我不擅长。他为什么会感到尴尬？
Oh, I'm not proud at all.
哦，我一点也不引以为傲。
You're not?
你不引以为傲？
No.
不。
But you get good deals.
但你总能买到实惠的东西。
So what? It's not a moral virtue to get good deals.
那又怎样？买到便宜货并不是一种道德美德。
It seems like it's smarter.
这看起来比较聪明。
I think so. There's an interesting thing, I think, here. I think people conflate getting good deals with like being moral or virtuous-- virtuous, right, like thrift or whatever. And I think that's wrong. I don't think it is virtuous to get a better deal on cashews.
我也这么认为。这里有一件有趣的事。我认为人们把买到便宜货和所谓的道德或美德混为一谈了，比如节俭之类的。我认为这是错的。我不认为在腰果上省钱是什么美德。
When you put it like that, I see. I don't know, but I--
你这么一说，我明白了。我不知道，但我——
I really don't, unless like every dollar I'm not spending on cashews I'm sending to the poor, which I'm not. I give some amount of money to charity, but it's not like the more I save, the more I'm giving to charity.
我真不觉得，除非我没花在腰果上的每一美元都捐给了穷人，而事实并非如此。我确实捐赠了一定数额的钱给慈善机构，但这并不是说我省得越多，捐得就越多。
But there's something about it that just-- it does seem like something to aspire to.
但这件事确实让人——让人觉得是一个值得向往的目标。
I don't think-- I mean, look, this doesn't really matter. This is just a thing that I do.
我不认为——听着，这其实没什么大不了的。这只是我做的一件事。
It's not a choice, he's saying. It's how he was brought up. So at this point, it's just him. It's not just grocery shopping. Jacob does this in all areas of his life.
他说这并不是选择。这是他的成长方式。所以到了现在，这就是他本人。这不仅仅是杂货购物。雅各布在生活的所有方面都这样做。
It can be paralyzing. He feels some shame that he's like this. And I feel shame that I am not like this.
这可能会让人瘫痪。他为自己这样感到羞耻。而我为自己不像他这样感到羞耻。
Money is a practical thing. How much do I have? What do I need? Can I afford it?
金钱是务实的东西。我有多少钱？我需要什么？我负担得起吗？
But getting your money's worth? That is much more personal because it's emotional. That's when you ask yourself, what's the most important thing to me? What might I regret? What should I sacrifice?
但要做到物有所值？那更加个人化，因为它关乎情感。那是当你问自己，什么对我最重要？我会后悔什么？我应该牺牲什么？
We have three stories about this today-- people trying to figure out if they're getting their money's worth, trying to figure out if they're getting one over on the world, or if the world is getting one over on them. First up, a man tries to get his money's worth out of the presidential election. Stay with us.
今天我们有三个关于这个的故事——人们试图弄清楚他们是否物有所值，试图弄清楚他们是在占世界的便宜，还是世界在占他们的便宜。首先，一个人试图在总统大选中实现他的“物有所值”。请留步。
Act One, The Final Countdown.
第一幕，最后的倒计时。
OK, so for the past six months, I've been covering the presidential election. And I've been particularly interested in this group of people who are trying to get the biggest bang for their buck out of this election season-- Republican donors, people who are in a rare position to put enormous sums into campaigns and watch what the money can do. People like this.
好的，过去六个月我一直在报道总统大选。我对这一群人特别感兴趣，他们试图在这次竞选季中获得最大的投资回报——共和党捐赠者，他们处于一种罕见的地位，可以将巨额资金投入竞选并观察这些钱能发挥什么作用。比如这些人。
So are you a billionaire?
你是亿万富翁吗？
No, I'm not. My father is.
不，我不是。我父亲是。
This is Doug Deason. He's a millionaire. His dad, Darwin Deason, is the billionaire. Years ago, the dad started a computer services company and made a ton of money in the 20 years since, rolling up and selling off companies. Just money making money. Five years ago, he sold it to Xerox.
这是道格·迪森。他是百万富翁。他的父亲达尔文·迪森是亿万富翁。多年前，他父亲创办了一家计算机服务公司，在随后的20年里通过收购和出售公司赚了一大笔钱。这纯粹是钱生钱。五年前，他把它卖给了施乐。
Now Doug, the son, manages their money and their political strategy. Doug is the one in charge of translating money into political power. He doesn't think of himself as a donor, exactly. There's much more thought and strategy than just throwing money at a campaign. He's more like an investor. He's looking around for the best place to put their money-- the best Republican place.
现在，儿子道格管理着他们的资金和政治战略。道格负责将金钱转化为政治影响力。他并不完全把自己看作是一个捐赠者。这其中包含了比单纯向竞选活动砸钱更多的思考和战略。他更像是一个投资者。他正在寻找存放他们资金的最佳场所——共和党的最佳场所。
Doug is a dedicated Republican, the kind who does not miss an opportunity to insult Democrats in any context. Take our first conversation. We were talking about his daily routine. He's 54. He's trim. He sees his trainer a few times a week. He just had a protein shake for breakfast, same as every morning.
道格是一个坚定的共和党人，那种在任何情况下都不会放过嘲讽民主党人机会的人。看看我们的第一次谈话。我们当时在谈论他的日常生活。他54岁，身材匀称。他每周见几次私人教练。他早餐只喝了一杯蛋白奶昔，和每天早上一样。
Every morning?
每天早上？
Every morning.
每天早上。
I feel like this is like a common thread. Some of the other donors I talked to, they're always running off to meet with their trainer or whatever and eating almond milk and blueberries for breakfast.
我觉得这像是一个共同点。我采访过的一些其他捐赠者，他们总是忙着去见教练什么的，早餐吃杏仁奶和蓝莓。
But you're talking about Republicans, who are winners and know how to run their life, not Democrats, who are losers and don't know how to run their life and want the government to give them a food pyramid to tell them how to eat, right?
但你谈论的是共和党人，他们是赢家，知道如何经营生活，而不是民主党人，他们是失败者，不知道如何经营自己的生活，还想要政府给他们一个饮食金字塔来告诉他们怎么吃饭，对吧？
How did you know?
你是怎么知道的？
I started talking to Doug at the beginning of the primaries, back in February.
我是在初选开始时，也就是二月份开始和道格交谈的。
Hey, Zoe.
嘿，佐伊。
Hey.
嘿。
What's happening?
发生什么事了？
Not much. What's happening with you?
没什么。你那边怎么样？
He and his dad budgeted $2 million for this election cycle. And over the last five months, over many phone calls and visits, I watched Doug try to figure out how to make the most of that money in one of the most confusing elections of his political life. His usual tricks failed, not because he was doing it wrong, but because the Republican donor playbook was being rewritten.
他和父亲为这次选举周期制定了200万美元的预算。在过去的五个月里，通过多次电话和访问，我看着道格试图弄清楚如何在他政治生涯中最令人困惑的一场选举中充分利用这笔钱。他平时的招数失灵了，不是因为他做错了，而是因为共和党的捐赠者剧本正在被改写。
For the Democrats, money and politics went pretty much as expected during the primaries. It wasn't like that at all for the Republicans. Here's the story of how it went down from the money's perspective.
对于民主党人来说，金钱和政治在初选期间的发展基本如预期。而共和党人则完全不是这样。这就是从金钱的角度来看事情是如何发展的。
To set the scene, Doug lives in one of the Republican capitals of the world, Dallas, Texas. He walks past former presidents while chatting on his cell phone.
为了交代背景，道格住在世界共和党之都之一——德克萨斯州达拉斯。他在打手机时路过前总统。
Literally, the reason I was hanging up so quick was President Bush was coming towards me as I was walking out of the garage in the office building.
说实话，我挂电话这么快是因为我正走出办公楼的车库时，布什总统正朝我走来。
Dallas is one of the best places in the world to raise Republican dollars. Like Doug says, hands down nothing-- nothing-- compares to Dallas.
达拉斯是世界上筹集共和党资金的最佳地点之一。正如道格所说，毫无疑问，没有任何地方能与达拉斯相比。
This election year started like usual. Every election cycle, the major candidates come to Dallas in search of big money and support from guys like Doug. Think of it like a cotillion ball. You've got the big Texas donors on one side of the room. On the other side, the candidates, trying to find dance partners.
这一选举年像往常一样开始。每个选举周期，主要的候选人都会来到达拉斯，寻求像道格这样的人的大笔资金和支持。把它想象成一场社交舞会。房间的一边是德克萨斯州的大金主们。另一边是候选人，试图找到舞伴。
Doug and his dad started out as Rick Perry supporters-- he'd been their governor-- but he dropped out. They started taking other meetings.
道格和他的父亲起初是里克·佩里的支持者——他是他们的州长——但他退出了。他们开始参加其他的会面。
Ben Carson. Super guy, very interesting.
本·卡森。超级棒的人，非常有意思。
But not savvy enough. Carly Fiorina.
但不够精明。卡莉·菲奥莉娜。
Brilliant. She'd be a great vice president.
才华横溢。她会是个很棒的副总统。
So no. Jeb Bush.
所以，不行。杰布·布什。
We went out, got in the car, and somebody said, well, that was thoroughly unimpressive.
我们出去坐进车里，有人说，嗯，那真是完全令人印象深刻。
Some of the meetings got testy. Doug fought with Marco Rubio over sugar subsidies. In a meeting with Ohio Governor John Kasich, Doug says he got in the governor's face because he thought Kasich implied that if they donated to his campaign, they'd get access to him when he became president.
有些会面变得很紧张。道格因为糖补贴问题与马可·卢比奥争执。在与俄亥俄州州长约翰·卡西奇的会面中，道格说他当面质问了州长，因为他认为卡西奇暗示如果他们向他的竞选活动捐款，当他成为总统后就能接触到他。
We don't care if you ever call us, or we ever see you, or you ever invite us to the White House. I will never spend the night in the Lincoln Bedroom. Neither will Dad. And we could give a [BLEEP] if we ever do. That's not the point.
我们不在乎你是否会给我们打电话，或者我们是否会见到你，或者你是否会邀请我们去白宫。我永远不会在林肯卧室过夜。我父亲也不会。如果我们真的那么做了，我们才不在乎呢。重点不是这个。
For the most part, though, business as usual. Some candidates got money and kept going. Some candidates flamed out. All this is happening in close consultation with people like Doug. One notable exception-- Donald Trump.
不过大部分情况下，生意照旧。一些候选人拿到了钱并继续前进。一些候选人失败了。这一切都是在与像道格这样的人密切协商的情况下发生的。一个显著的例外——唐纳德·特朗普。
While Doug was meeting with candidates, Trump was making a big show of not being one of those puppets-- his word-- who depended on other rich people's money.
当道格在与候选人会面时，特朗普大张旗鼓地表现出他不是那些依赖其他富人钱财的“傀儡”——用他的话来说。
And those PACs control the candidates, OK? They totally control. Carson is controlled by his PAC. Bush is controlled by his PAC.
那些超级政治行动委员会控制着候选人，懂吗？完全控制。卡森被他的超级政治行动委员会控制。布什被他的超级政治行动委员会控制。
Rubio is controlled by his PAC, and he needs a lot of water on top of everything else. Did you ever see a guy-- did you ever see a guy sweat like Rubio? I've never seen  anything like it.
卢比奥被他的超级政治行动委员会控制，而且除了这一切之外，他还需要大量的水。你见过有人——你见过像卢比奥那样出汗的人吗？我从来没见过这样的事。
Trump was out there conspicuously ignoring the donors. Doug was ignoring Trump, too.
特朗普在外面显眼地无视捐赠者。道格也在无视特朗普。
If you fast-forward through the debates, you can get through pretty fast. And when Trump's talking, I'll fast-forward through most of that because he can talk all day, but you don't really learn anything.
如果你在辩论中快进，你可以过得很快。当特朗普说话时，我会快进大部分内容，因为他可以讲一整天，但你真的学不到任何东西。
This situation can't stand. No Republican nominee in recent history has made it to the presidency without Texas money, without the help of people like Doug. And Trump is going to be the nominee. But in March 2016, deep into the primaries, they are still paying no attention to each other.
这种情况不能持续。近现代历史上没有哪位共和党提名人能没有德克萨斯州的资金，没有像道格这样的人的帮助就入主白宫。而特朗普将成为提名人。但在2016年3月，初选正如火如荼时，他们仍然完全不关注对方。
April 2016, Doug and his dad have done their due diligence. They took all the meetings. They have their guy, Ted Cruz. They put in a couple hundred thousand dollars into a super PAC for him, and Doug has put in some time.
2016年4月，道格和他的父亲已经做了他们的尽职调查。他们参加了所有的会面。他们有了支持的人选，特德·克鲁兹。他们为他筹集的超级政治行动委员会投入了十几万美元，道格也投入了一些时间。
He's calling other donors as candidates drop out, trying to win them to Cruz. Three days before the all-important Indiana primary, Doug helps pull off a big endorsement. He gets Indiana Governor Mike Pence to back Cruz. I talked to him right as it was happening.
随着候选人退出，他在给其他捐赠者打电话，试图把他们争取到克鲁兹这边。在至关重要的印第安纳州初选前三天，道格帮助促成了一次重要的背书。他让印第安纳州州长迈克·彭斯支持克鲁兹。就在这件事发生时，我和他谈过。
Oh, here they're announcing it on Fox right now. I think he's about to do his-- looks like he's about to do his-- is he about to do it? We'll see. Yep. Yep, yep, yep, yep, yep. He's just about to announce.
哦，他们现在在福克斯新闻上宣布了。我想他快要——看起来他快要——他快要宣布了吗？我们走着瞧。是的。是的，是的，是的，是的，是的。他就要宣布了。
Yeah, we're holding a fundraiser for him. Mike and I are pretty good friends and we're doing a big fundraiser for him here in Dallas on May 31. And-- oh, look. There's Ted and Carly with him. Pretty cool.
是的，我们正在为他举办筹款活动。我和迈克是非常好的朋友，我们5月31日在达拉斯为他举行了一场大型筹款活动。而且——哦，你看。特德和卡莉正和他在一起。真酷。
Oh, and that [BLEEP]-off Hannity. Sean Hannity. What a lame-- gah. I can't stand him.
哦，还有那个叫汉尼提的混蛋。肖恩·汉尼提。真是个废物——该死。我真受不了他。
Doug's guy endorses Cruz. Primary night arrives, and Ted Cruz drops out of the race.
道格支持的人背书了克鲁兹。初选之夜到来，特德·克鲁兹退出了竞选。
May 2016, there's one man standing, and it's Donald Trump, the one guy Doug hasn't vetted. Mike Pence has reappeared recently as Trump's vice presidential pick. Doug's money seems to have done nothing.
2016年5月，只剩下一个人了，那就是唐纳德·特朗普，道格唯一没有审查过的人。迈克·彭斯最近作为特朗普的竞选伙伴重新出现。道格的钱似乎什么都没做。
In fact, after $645 million dollars spent by these candidates and their super PACs over the course of the primary race, the money did not pick the candidate. It was a brand-new, unwritten chapter.
事实上，在这些候选人和他们的超级政治行动委员会在初选过程中花费了6.45亿美元之后，金钱并没有选出候选人。这是一个全新的、未被书写的篇章。
Beginning of June, Trump's got $1.3 million in cash. That's nothing in this world. Hillary Clinton's campaign has $43 million in the bank. GOP donors are holding back, unsure if Trump even needs the money.
六月初，特朗普有130万美元的现金。在这个世界里这算不了什么。希拉里·克林顿的竞选团队银行里有4300万美元。共和党捐赠者在观望，不确定特朗普是否真的需要这笔钱。
Is he going to just keep funding his own campaign? Is he going to start raising money from other rich people? Once one jumps in with a lot of money, more jump in. Millions beget millions. In short, Trump needs Doug now.
他是要继续资助他自己的竞选活动吗？还是他要开始从其他富人那里筹钱？一旦有一个人投入大量资金，更多的人就会跟进。金钱吸引金钱。简而言之，特朗普现在需要道格。
Am I excited about Trump? No, I'm not. You might be able to tell from the tone of my voice I'm not enthusiastic about Trump.
我对特朗普感到兴奋吗？不，我没有。你可能从我的语气中听出来，我对特朗普并不热衷。
I'm disappointed that Governor Perry's not going to be our next president of the United States. I'm disappointed that Ted Cruz is not going to be our next president of the United States. You know, I think Jeb would have made a fine president. He didn't have a chance of getting there, obviously.
我感到失望的是佩里州长没有成为我们下一任美国总统。我感到失望的是特德·克鲁兹没有成为我们下一任美国总统。你知道，我认为杰布本来会成为一位出色的总统。显然，他没有机会达到那个位置。
But I think that we have some really good options. I don't know what we're going to get with Trump.
但我认为我们有一些非常好的选择。我不知道特朗普会带来什么。
The moneyed Republicans start choosing sides, just like the Republican voters did after Trump won the primary-- Yes, Trump or Never Trump. Doug has to figure out what to do next with his money.
财大气粗的共和党人开始站队，就像特朗普赢得初选后的共和党选民一样——支持特朗普或“绝不特朗普”。道格必须弄清楚他的钱接下来该怎么用。
One of the most influential Republican donors in the country comes out in April and says he can't do it-- Charles Koch. He can't stand Trump. Asked about Trump's idea to register Muslims, Koch said, "That's monstrous. This isn't Nazi Germany." He said that Trump's behavior is the opposite of what the Koch network stands for.
全国最有影响力的共和党捐赠者之一在四月份站出来说他做不到——查尔斯·科赫。他无法忍受特朗普。当被问及特朗普关于登记穆斯林的提议时，科赫说：“那太骇人听闻了。这不是纳粹德国。”他说特朗普的行为与科赫网络所代表的一切背道而驰。
This complicates Doug's decision about whether to invest in Trump because Doug thinks of Charles Koch as his mentor, his guru, almost.
这让道格在是否投资特朗普的问题上变得复杂，因为道格几乎把查尔斯·科赫视为他的导师，他的精神领袖。
Charles Koch has certainly been one of the most influential people in my life. I admire everything that he does and what he stands for. You know, I say that I often get accused of drinking the Charles Koch Kool-Aid. And I said, as a matter of fact, I have it for breakfast instead of orange juice. I drink it at lunch instead of iced tea. And I have it with vodka at night. It's pretty nice.
查尔斯·科赫无疑是我生命中最有影响力的人之一。我钦佩他所做的一切和他所代表的一切。你知道，我常说我常被指控喝了“查尔斯·科赫的酷爱饮料”（被洗脑）。我说，事实上，我早餐喝它代替橙汁。午餐喝它代替冰茶。晚上把它和伏特加一起喝。味道真不错。
You might already know about the Koch brothers. David and Charles are the famous ones. There's been a lot of reporting about them.
你可能已经听说过科赫兄弟了。大卫和查尔斯是其中出名的。关于他们的报道有很多。
The main agenda of the Kochs is this-- smaller government. That means no EPA, no Department of Education, little regulation, low taxes, cut back on Medicare, Medicaid, Social Security, basically get rid of all the programs that have been put in place since LBJ's War on Poverty, no corporate subsidies.
科赫兄弟的主要议程是这个——小政府。这意味着没有环保局，没有教育部，少监管，低税收，削减医疗保险、医疗补助、社会保障，基本上废除自林登·约翰逊“向贫困宣战”以来实施的所有项目，没有企业补贴。
During those days of back-to-back candidate interviews with Carson, Bush, Rubio, Fiorina, Doug and his dad asked everyone the same questions. They had this checklist based on the Koch way of thinking. What did the candidate intend to do about corporate subsidies, any kind of subsidies, getting power back to the states?
在与卡森、布什、卢比奥、菲奥莉娜进行连续不断的候选人面试期间，道格和他的父亲问了每个人同样的问题。他们有一份基于科赫思维方式的清单。候选人打算如何处理企业补贴、任何形式的补贴，将权力归还给各州？
Doug went to his first Koch seminar in 2011, and that's where he got religion. Before Charles Koch came into his life, Doug and his dad gave money locally, and yeah, to presidential candidates, but not to PACs. Instead, he and his dad would meet a candidate. If they seemed nice and conservative, they'd throw money at the candidate. It was all about the people. Now he talks about it like this.
道格在2011年参加了他的第一次科赫研讨会，就在那里他有了“宗教信仰”。在查尔斯·科赫进入他的生活之前，道格和他的父亲在当地捐款，是的，也给总统候选人捐款，但不是给政治行动委员会。相反，他和父亲会见一位候选人。如果他们看起来既友善又保守，他们就会向这位候选人扔钱。这全是关于人的。现在他这样谈论它。
So this is a battle, not a war. So short term, we give directly to the candidates' campaigns.
所以这是一场战斗，而不是战争。因此，短期内，我们直接捐给候选人的竞选活动。
The candidates are just there to fight the battle. It's not only about the candidates anymore. The candidates are the soldiers fighting to put in place the big ideas. The big ideas come from the think tanks. And that's what the war is over, the big ideas.
候选人只是在那里打仗。现在这不仅仅是关于候选人了。候选人是打仗的士兵，目的是落实那些宏大的理念。宏大的理念来自智囊团。而这就是战争的目的所在，宏大的理念。
And then the war is influencing legislation, influencing the way things are taught, history is taught, economics is taught at universities-- getting a conservative footprint on liberal universities. So that's the think tanks.
接下来的战争是影响立法，影响事物的教授方式，历史的教授方式，经济学在大学的教授方式——让保守派在自由派大学里留下足迹。这就是智囊团的作用。
Now that's where most of the Deason money goes-- to the war, to their favorite think tank, the Texas Public Policy Foundation and also to Freedom Partners, the umbrella organization run by the Koch brothers.
现在大部分迪森的钱都流向了那里——流向了战争，流向了他们最喜欢的智囊团，德克萨斯公共政策基金会，也流向了“自由伙伴”，即由科赫兄弟经营的伞形组织。
The one bipartisan issue the Kochs and Doug support is criminal justice reform, especially regarding sentencing. And Doug is really into this one. This was high on the list of questions he asked candidates.
科赫兄弟和道格支持的唯一两党议题是刑事司法改革，尤其是关于量刑的问题。道格真的很热衷于这个。这在他问候选人的问题清单上名列前茅。
He recently wrote an op-ed about how his own arrest when he was young could have ruined his chances for success if he'd been charged with a felony. It was a big spread in the New York Times , even though he claims the paper bursts into flames whenever he touches it.
他最近写了一篇专栏文章，讲述了他年轻时被捕的经历，如果他被指控犯有重罪，本来可能会毁掉他成功的机会。这篇文章在《纽约时报》上占据了很大版面，尽管他声称只要他一碰这份报纸，报纸就会自燃。
Also, it's an economic issue. Locking up so many people costs Texas a lot of money. The Deasons and the Kochs funded a new criminal justice research center in Dallas. Doug was hugely influential in getting a new law passed in Texas last year to seal certain criminal records.
此外，这也是一个经济问题。关押这么多人让德克萨斯州花费巨大。迪森家族和科赫家族在达拉斯资助了一个新的刑事司法研究中心。道格在去年推动德克萨斯州通过一项关于封存某些犯罪记录的新法律方面极具影响力。
So that's how he thinks of his political spending now, like his money is part of this long-term, change-the-world strategy. His money has meaning. That checklist of priorities-- small government, criminal justice reform, ending government subsidies-- Trump hasn't said anything about those things. At least, nothing that seems like it would appeal to Doug and his dad.
所以他现在就是这样看待他的政治支出的，就像他的钱是这个长期的、改变世界战略的一部分。他的钱有意义。那份优先事项清单——小政府、刑事司法改革、结束政府补贴——特朗普对这些事情只字未提。至少，没有什么看起来能吸引道格和他父亲的东西。
I watched as he came in. How did I know he was coming? Because there were a bunch of helicopters, and they were hovering over his entourage.
我看着他进来。我是怎么知道他要来的？因为有一群直升机，它们盘旋在他的随行人员上方。
Of course, Trump does show up in Dallas in the middle of June. He's got no money and a brand new deal with the RNC, and they got him to suck up his pride and realize that what serious candidates do is they go ask for money. Trump Force One is landing in Love Field.
当然，特朗普确实在六月中旬出现在达拉斯。他没钱，和共和党全国委员会有一项全新的协议，他们让他放下身段，意识到严肃的候选人应该做的事情就是去要钱。“特朗普一号”正在降落在爱田机场。
You could watch it all the way from Love Field, all the way through Highland Park, right past down here, across that little bridge down there. And then there were news helicopters just following along.
你可以从爱田机场一直看着它，穿过高地公园，就在这下面，穿过那边那座小桥。然后新闻直升机一直跟着。
Trump's got three meetings scheduled with rich guys, including Doug and his dad. It's set for Friday, June 17. I talked to Doug the night before.
特朗普安排了三场与富人的会面，包括道格和他父亲。时间定在6月17日星期五。我在前一天晚上和道格谈过。
So we're not going to make a commitment to him until we meet him. So Dad and his wife Katerina and I are headed over in the morning to his hotel to spend 30 minutes with him in private, just ask him some questions. Where do you stand on criminal justice reform, corporate cronyism, entitlement programs, Social Security, that kind of thing-- you know, food stamps, which is part of the farm subsidies, for some stupid reason. How do you feel about farm subsidies?
所以除非见到他，否则我们不会对他做出承诺。所以爸爸、他的妻子卡特琳娜和我明天早上要去他的酒店花30分钟私下见他，问他一些问题。你在刑事司法改革、企业裙带关系、福利项目、社会保障、那类事情上立场如何——你知道，食品券，出于某种愚蠢的原因，它是农场补贴的一部分。你对农场补贴感觉如何？
What is it actually going to be like? Are you going to sit down with him in a room and just say to him, how do you feel about corporate subsidies? Just like that?
实际上会是什么样？你要坐在房间里，直接对他说，你对企业补贴感觉如何？就这样吗？
Right.
对。
Here are the options. He can donate to the campaign itself, up to $5,400. He'll probably do at least that much, but he can do way more. He can donate to the Trump Victory Fund, which was set up by the RNC to raise money for Trump in some congressional races. The cap is for $450,000. And he can donate as much as he likes, of course, to a super PAC that's supporting Trump.
这是选项。他可以向竞选活动本身捐款，最多5400美元。他可能至少会捐那么多，但他可以做更多。他可以向特朗普胜利基金捐款，这是共和党全国委员会设立的，为特朗普在一些国会竞选中筹集资金。上限是45万美元。当然，他可以随心所欲地向支持特朗普的超级政治行动委员会捐款。
What about Charles Koch? Have you talked to him about meeting with Trump?
查尔斯·科赫呢？你和他谈过见特朗普的事吗？
No, we haven't. No.
不，我们还没有。不。
Why?
为什么？
Dad-- we will. We probably will. Dad voiced his frustration over the Charles interview a few Sundays ago. And his statement that he couldn't support Trump-- and he kind of insinuated that if Hillary softened her rhetoric and did certain things, he might even consider supporting and/or voting for her.
爸爸——我们会谈的。我们可能会谈。爸爸在几个星期前的某个星期天对查尔斯的采访表示了沮丧。他说他无法支持特朗普——他甚至暗示如果希拉里软化她的言辞并做某些事情，他甚至可能会考虑支持和/或投票给她。
And obviously, Dad didn't take that very well. And so he let the Koch team know. So Charles sent him a very detailed letter.
显然，爸爸对那番话听得不顺耳。所以他让科赫团队知道了。查尔斯给他寄了一封非常详细的信。
Before his involvement with the Kochs, Doug was just a rich Republican. Post-Koch, he's a warrior, and that feels good. The Kochs have provided a map for political donors and a community for billionaires. It's called the Koch network. The idea is they can act as one unit, leveraging hundreds of millions of dollars toward their goals. Doug loves being part of that. He believes in it. And now Trump is rattling the unity of the Koch network. This letter from Charles to Doug's dad confirms that.
在与科赫合作之前，道格只是一个富有的共和党人。与科赫合作后，他成了一名战士，这种感觉很好。科赫为政治捐赠者提供了一张地图，为亿万富翁提供了一个社区。它被称为科赫网络。想法是他们可以作为一个整体行动，动用数亿美元朝着他们的目标努力。道格喜欢成为其中的一部分。他相信它。现在特朗普正在扰乱科赫网络的团结。查尔斯写给道格父亲的这封信证实了这一点。
So Dad got it. He read it. Called me. They cc'ed me. He said, what do you think I should do? I said, I don't know. Let's meet Trump first and see how passionate we are about him, what we think about him. Maybe we ask Charles to meet with him, at least give him a chance.
所以爸爸收到了。他读了。打了电话给我。他们抄送了我。他说，你认为我该怎么办？我说，我不知道。让我们先见见特朗普，看看我们对他有多热情，我们对他怎么想。也许我们请查尔斯和他见个面，至少给他一个机会。
Does it feel weird, like your two dads are fighting?
这感觉奇怪吗，就像你的两个爸爸在打架？
Well, no. I mean, Charles is not my dad. He's obviously hugely influential on me and what I focus on in life and my political thinking.
嗯，不。我的意思是，查尔斯不是我的父亲。他在我生活中关注的事物和政治思想方面显然非常有影响力。
I know your analysis, but I mean, does it feel bad to have your dad and Charles Koch disagree?
我知道你的分析，但我的意思是，让你的父亲和查尔斯·科赫意见不合，感觉不好吗？
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, it does.
是的。是的。是的，确实如此。
Why?
为什么？
I don't know. We've always been-- Dad and I are 99.9% of the time on the same page, and I kind of see where Charles is coming from.
我不知道。我们一直——爸爸和我99.9%的时间意见一致，我有点明白查尔斯是从什么角度出发的。
The day Doug met with Trump, I meet up with him in his office right after.
道格和特朗普会面的那天，我在会后在他的办公室里见到了他。
So what happened?
发生了什么？
We just went over and-- went over to the Park Cities Hilton. And we met with Donald Trump.
我们刚过去——去了公园城市希尔顿酒店。我们见到了唐纳德·特朗普。
So to start from the beginning, Trump kept them waiting. They're sitting in the hotel lobby. At one point, Doug checks in with his dad.
从头说起吧，特朗普让他们等了一会儿。他们坐在酒店大堂里。有一次，道格和他父亲确认了一下。
I go, what are you going to talk to him about? He said, oh, I don't know, whatever pops up. He goes, I'm kind of counting on you. I said, OK. Well, here's-- and I had a piece of paper, read through it. He said, perfect.
我问，你打算和他谈什么？他说，哦，我不知道，想到什么谈什么。他说，我指望你了。我说，好的。好的——我有张纸，读了一遍。他说，完美。
Where's that piece of paper?
那张纸在哪？
Right here in front of me.
就在我面前。
Can I see it? "Admit you are not perfect, not without sin, but who isn't? Stop racial remarks. OK, it's criminal justice reform, corporate cronyism, federalism. How does he feel about big government and states and stuff?"
我能看看吗？“承认你不完美，并非没有罪，但谁又是呢？停止种族歧视言论。好的，是刑事司法改革、企业裙带关系、联邦制。他对于大政府和州权之类的感觉如何？”
Getting power back to the states, yeah.
将权力归还给州，是的。
Did you ask him about that?
你问他那个了吗？
No. Didn't get a chance. He's just such a nice guy. He's so pleasant and so personable in person.
没有。没机会。他真是个好人。他非常和蔼，面对面时非常平易近人。
Did you ask any of your questions about your issues?
你问了关于你的议题的问题吗？
No, not really. I did some. I'd kind of research some online a little bit, and I felt pretty good about them. But I didn't expect Dad to talk as much as he did.
不，并没有。我问了一些。我在网上做了一些研究，我感觉还不错。但我没想到爸爸会说那么多。
What did he say?
他说了什么？
The reason he did is because Trump just engaged him, asked him about Dad's business, how did he make his money. And they talked about-- he kept complimenting down on me that he's got-- I know how great it is to be able to turn something over to your kids and let them run it and let them do it, which obviously is what I do. So it was nice to be complimented, right?
他之所以那么做，是因为特朗普直接与他互动，问他爸爸的生意，他是怎么赚钱的。他们谈论——他一直称赞我，说他有——我知道能够把事业交给孩子并让他们运行、让他们去做是多么伟大，这显然就是我所做的。所以被称赞真好，对吧？
By Trump or by your dad?
是特朗普称赞的，还是你父亲？
By anybody. They were both saying that, so that was really nice.
被任何人称赞都好。他们两个都在那么说，所以真好。
They didn't discuss subsidies or criminal justice reform or any of the other issues because something else was at work on Doug in that room. Something more visceral than long-term strategizing about conservative ideas. From the sounds of it, Trump just charmed him. And suddenly it's morning in Dallas.
他们没有讨论补贴或刑事司法改革或任何其他议题，因为在那个房间里，道格身上发生了其他事情。比长期战略化保守理念更发自内心的东西。听起来，特朗普只是对他施展了魅力。突然间，达拉斯的早晨到来了。
You know, he said many times, things are just great. Things are really great. Things are really great. Things are really going good. If there was a pause in the discussion, it would come out with that. Things are really good.
你知道，他说过很多次，事情非常好。事情真的非常好。事情真的非常好。事情真的进展很顺利。如果讨论中有停顿，就会冒出那句话。事情真的很好。
And you walked out of that meeting and what did you and your dad say to each other?
你走出那个会场时，你和你父亲说了什么？
Just, hey, that went really well. He's a really nice guy, and seems to think a lot like we do. He believes that a businessman-- at the end of the day, a country is a business.
只是，嘿，那太顺利了。他真是个好人，看起来想法和我们很像。他相信一个商人——归根结底，国家就是一种生意。
What made you think he believes that? You didn't ask him about that stuff.
是什么让你认为他相信这一点？你没有问他那些事。
No, but he said it. I mean, he just talked about, hey, you guys are businessmen. You understand how a business works. Really, that's how a country works.
不，但他说了。我的意思是，他只是谈到，嘿，你们是商人。你们明白生意是怎么运作的。真的，国家就是那样运作的。
And this country needs to be run like a business. We need to cut costs and support people where they need to be supported and cut fat out and bloat. I'm a businessman. I've run businesses. That's what I intend to do. And that's why we voted for Ross Perot twice. Threw away our vote there.
而且这个国家需要像经营生意一样来管理。我们需要削减成本，在需要支持的地方支持人们，剔除脂肪和臃肿。我是个商人。我经营过企业。这就是我打算做的。这就是为什么我们两次投票给罗斯·佩罗。白白浪费了我们的选票。
Then Doug pulls out his phone.
然后道格掏出了他的手机。
There we are. So that's Dad, Trump, and me.
在那儿。那是爸爸、特朗普和我。
Three businessmen-- Doug, Dad, Trump-- suits and ties, thumbs up. There you go. That's the decision.
三个商人——道格、爸爸、特朗普——西装革履，竖起大拇指。你看，这就是决定。
To be clear, Doug and his father don't have any special insight into Trump's policies or thinking. They know the same things regular voters know about what he's going to do. But in this meeting, Doug wasn't choosing between Republicans. He'd set aside the war of big ideas in that room. He focused on the battle against Hillary Clinton. This has turned into a team sport for him, and there is really only one team that Doug can be on.
需要明确的是，道格和他的父亲对特朗普的政策或想法没有任何特殊的见解。他们知道普通选民关于他会做什么的那些事。但在这次会面中，道格并不是在共和党人之间做选择。在那个房间里，他把那些宏大的理念战争搁置一旁。他专注于反对希拉里·克林顿的战斗。对他来说，这已经演变成了一项团队运动，而且道格确实只能加入其中一个团队。
The Deasons are going to do a lot more than $5,400. Here's the plan. Between Doug and his dad, they're giving $900,000 to the Trump Victory Fund. Dad's going to throw a fundraiser at Laguna Beach. Doug's going to call around to find the right super PAC for supporting Trump and then maybe give the PAC a million, or two, or three.
迪森家族要做的远不止5400美元。计划如下。在道格和他父亲之间，他们要向特朗普胜利基金捐款90万美元。爸爸要在拉古纳海滩举行一场筹款活动。道格要四处打电话寻找合适的超级政治行动委员会来支持特朗普，然后可能会给那个委员会一百万、两百万或三百万美元。
I had my Trump jerseys dropped off today.
我今天收到了我的特朗普球衣。
Oh, gosh. What are these?
哦，天哪。这些是什么？
Trump jerseys.
特朗普球衣。
I saw a bunch of these for Ted Cruz.
我为特德·克鲁兹见过一堆这样的。
Yeah, same guys made them. It's Toby Neugebauer.
是的，同一个人做的。那是托比·纽格鲍尔。
You are like those guys. You just move on to the next one.
你就像那些人。你只是转移到下一个目标。
Well, no. It's a Republican.
嗯，不。这是一个共和党人。
I know.
我知道。
Yeah.
是的。
I know.
我知道。
You're right.
你是对的。
There are a lot of Republicans like Doug, apparently. Trump's gone from that million dollars at the beginning of June, when he hadn't figured anything out, to $51 million just last week, according to The Washington Post . Half of that money is grassroots-- people getting online. Half of that is the Dougs of the world maxing out with the RNC, and Charles Koch.
显然，有很多像道格这样的共和党人。根据《华盛顿邮报》的数据，特朗普已经从六月初那一无所知的一百万美元，增加到了上周的5100万美元。其中一半的资金来自基层——人们上网捐款。另一半是像道格这样的人在共和党全国委员会上限额捐款，还有查尔斯·科赫。
So you're going to call Charles and say you met with Trump. And you're going to say--
所以你要打电话给查尔斯，说你见过特朗普了。你要说——
We'll probably send him a letter back.
我们可能会给他回信。
Uh-huh. And what are you going to say?
嗯。你要说什么？
Just say, hey, we met with him. We had the opportunity to meet with him. We were withholding judgment on him until we met with him. Now that we've had time to spend time with him, we intend to support him financially. We think that it would be in everyone's best interest, and your own, and the network's, if you would meet with him.
就说，嘿，我们见过他了。我们有机会见过他。我们一直对他持保留意见，直到我们见到他。既然我们已经有时间和他在一起了，我们打算在经济上支持他。我们认为，如果你们能和他见面，对大家，对你，对网络都有好处。
But I just got an email from Doug last weekend. He wrote, "Charles is not ready to meet with Trump yet. He may never be."
但我上周末刚收到道格的一封邮件。他写道：“查尔斯还没准备好见特朗普。他可能永远都不会准备好。”
Coming up, a high school principal loses his morals over boots. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，一位高中校长因为靴子丢掉了他的道德准则。这是芝加哥公共广播电台在节目继续后的报道。
It's This American Life . I'm Zoe Chace, sitting in for Ira Glass. Today, we're talking about getting your money's worth for things, and just how powerful that drive can be to spend our money wisely. Sometimes it's millions of dollars, but now we're at Act Two, Bean Counters.
这里是《美国生活》。我是佐伊·蔡斯，代替艾拉·格拉斯。今天，我们在讨论关于物有所值，以及这种驱动力让我们明智地花钱是多么强大。有时这是数百万美元的生意，但现在我们进入第二幕，斤斤计较的人。
There's a way to calculate how satisfied we are, as a country, with all of our things. It's done by the American Customer Satisfaction Index. Of course, we are never satisfied, but in the last two years, this little index has been in a nosedive, which is weird. Like, what was so great about two years ago? Apparently, we are epically dissatisfied with all the things-- health insurance, cable, government, airlines.
有一种方法可以计算作为一个国家，我们对所有物品的满意度。它是由美国客户满意度指数完成的。当然，我们永远不会满足，但在过去两年里，这个小指数一直在暴跌，这很奇怪。比如，两年前有什么那么好？显然，我们对所有的东西都非常不满意——健康保险、有线电视、政府、航空公司。
This is why I like this next story. It's a test. What happens if you guarantee complete, eternal, 100% satisfaction to the habitually unsatisfied? Sara Corbett has this story.
这就是我为什么喜欢下一个故事的原因。这是一个测试。如果你向习惯性不满的人保证完全、永恒、100%的满意度，会发生什么？萨拉·科比特带来了这个故事。
Here's a story my friend Derek tells for penance-- those are his words, for penance-- a story in which he says he's--
这是我的朋友德里克为了赎罪而讲述的故事——这是他的话，为了赎罪——一个他说自己当时——
Being a dirtbag.
像个卑鄙小人。
Maybe even more than a dirtbag.
可能比卑鄙小人更糟糕。
Total sleazebag.
完全是个混蛋。
Because we're in America, this morality tale takes place in a customer service department at LL Bean in Maine, where we both live. This story involves a pair of cross-country ski boots.
因为我们在美国，这个道德故事发生在缅因州的一家LL Bean客户服务部，我们都住那里。这个故事涉及一双越野滑雪靴。
I had these boots that were given when we were first married.
我有一双靴子，是我们刚结婚时别人送的。
When was that?
那是什么时候？
'92. And so this was maybe-- we'll say 2007 or something, maybe later than that. And one of the boots gave out. And it had LL Bean written right on it, so I knew where it came from.
92年。所以这大概是——我们说是2007年左右或者更晚吧。其中一只靴子坏了。上面写着LL Bean，所以我知道它是哪来的。
What had you heard?
你听说过什么？
Yeah, the understanding is that they will accept returns at any time for no reason at all, for any reason. So I decided I had to test if this was true. So I went and I remember the woman pretty clearly. And she asked a few questions.
是的，大家都知道他们接受在任何时间、没有任何理由的情况下退货。所以我决定测试一下这是不是真的。所以我去了，我还记得那个女人，很清楚。她问了几个问题。
And she says, so when did you get the boots? And I said, I don't recall exactly. They were a gift. And she said, roughly how long ago? And I said, I don't know, maybe 15 years? She said, thank you. So what is your reason for return? They just fell apart.
她说，那么你是什么时候买的靴子？我说，我不记得确切时间了。这是别人送的礼物。她说，大概多久以前？我说，不知道，大概15年吧？她说，谢谢。那么你退货的理由是什么？它们坏了。
After 15 years.
15年之后。
Thank you. So were you satisfied with their performance? Yeah, they were great. They just wore out. Thank you. You get the sense I could say anything and they'd say thank you. Here you go.
谢谢。那么你对它们的性能满意吗？是的，它们很棒。它们只是磨损了。谢谢。你感觉我说什么，他们都会说谢谢。给你。
And with each kind of bit of her gratitude, my shame just expanded till it was supersize. And then she gave me the check for the amount of the boots, and I went and got new boots.
随着她每一次感激，我的羞愧感不断膨胀，直到超标。然后她给了我一张支票，金额是靴子的价格，我再去买了新靴子。
Technically speaking, this is allowed at LL Bean under their return policy. Technically. No one at the store was going to tell Derek to his face that he had done anything wrong. But that didn't make it feel right.
从技术上讲，根据他们的退货政策，这在LL Bean是被允许的。从技术上讲。店里没有人会当面告诉德里克他做错了什么。但这并没让它感觉正确。
I had the long drive home of shame. It felt like every police officer was on notice, and they would now know who I really was as a human being because I returned boots and got a free pair for no good reason.
我开车回家的路上满是羞愧。感觉每个警察都在注意，他们现在会知道我作为一个人到底是什么样的，因为我退回了靴子并无缘无故地拿到了免费的一双。
And tell us what you do for a living, Derek.
德里克，告诉我们你是做什么工作的。
I'm a high school principal. I try to shape the young minds of tomorrow to make correct moral choices.
我是一位高中校长。我试图塑造明天的年轻头脑，让他们做出正确的道德选择。
I started asking around, just curious to see who else had sailed into the moral Bermuda Triangle that is the LL Bean returns desk. A different friend of mine told me he had been returning his elementary school backpack every five years or so since sixth grade. He's now 30.
我开始四处打听，只是好奇谁还曾驶入LL Bean退货柜台这个道德百慕大三角。我的另一个朋友告诉我，从六年级开始，他每五年左右就会退回他的小学生书包。他现在30岁了。
I made a quick phone call to another guy about another backpack.
我给另一个人打了个快速电话，关于另一个书包。
Hey, Matt.
嘿，马特。
Sara, hey. How's it going?
萨拉，嘿。怎么样？
This is my brother Matt. He bought his backpack at the beginning of one summer in college then spent three months camping in the woods of New Hampshire, doing trail maintenance for a summer job. He lived out of that backpack-- an LL Bean backpack-- for three months before deciding it wasn't roomy enough. So he took himself, and it, to the returns desk.
这是我弟弟马特。他在大学第一个暑假开始时买了书包，然后在那里待了三个月，在纽罕布什尔州的树林里露营，做暑期工修路。在那三个月里，他靠那个书包——一个LL Bean书包——生活，然后觉得空间不够大。所以他带着自己和书包去了退货柜台。
It was trashed, but it was still usable. And it was all greasy from like-- they get all greasy and smelly and stuff like that. The bug dope we use is Old Woodsman.
它破破烂烂的，但还能用。而且因为各种原因，它变得油腻腻的，又脏又臭。我们用的驱蚊药是“老伐木工”。
This particular bug dope is made with pine tar, which is very sticky. Sticks to everything. And then everything sticks to it-- pine needles, dirt, dead bugs. So all of this was on Matt's backpack along with three months of young man back sweat.
这种特殊的驱蚊药是用松焦油做的，非常粘。粘在每样东西上。然后每样东西都粘在它上面——松针、泥土、死虫子。所以所有这些都在马特的书包上，再加上三个月年轻人的后背汗水。
Matt is clear-- and was clear at the time-- that it wasn't LL Bean's fault that he bought a too-small backpack. It was his fault.
马特很清楚——当时也很清楚——买了个太小的书包不是LL Bean的错。是他的错。
Oh, absolutely. Yeah. But then again, I had heard that you could return stuff. And I was like, well, would they really take this back?
哦，绝对是的。但另一方面，我听说你可以退货。我就想，好吧，他们真的会收回这个吗？
Yes, they did, and so, so much more. LL Bean sells a lot of stuff, all kinds. It's sort of like Target, but for outdoorsy New Englanders, and a lot more expensive. Part of the reason it's more expensive is because the company, which has been around since 1912, claims their products are extra high quality, built to last. And the company's return policy is built to last, too. Other stores give you a week, a month, maybe a year. LL Bean gives you forever.
是的，他们收了，而且远不止如此。LL Bean卖很多东西，各种各样的。有点像塔吉特百货，但针对的是喜欢户外活动的新英格兰人，而且贵得多。它更贵的部分原因是，这家自1912年以来就存在的公司声称他们的产品质量超高，经久耐用。公司的退货政策也经久耐用。其他商店给你一周、一个月、可能一年的时间。LL Bean给你永远。
And I sort of knew that. I knew the gist of their policy, or at least the urban legend version of it. For 19 years, I've lived down the highway from the flagship store in Freeport, Maine. I have friends who work there. But I didn't know that people were truly, truly returning 15-year-old boots and getting away with it. Is anyone calling bull-[BLEEP] on this? Is anyone on either side of these transactions drawing the line?
我大概知道。我知道他们政策的要点，或者至少是都市传说版本。19年来，我一直住在缅因州弗里波特旗舰店附近。我有在那里工作的朋友。但我不知道人们真的在退回15年前的靴子还能蒙混过关。有人在质疑这个吗？在这些交易的任何一方有人划清界限吗？
Once I started looking into it, it felt more and more like LL Bean's return policy is this giant, 100-year-old psych experiment.
一旦我开始研究，它感觉越来越像LL Bean的退货政策是一个巨大的、100年的心理实验。
You just bring it back and we'll give you-- honestly give you-- as much money for it as humanly possible. That was told to me by the guy who trained me.
你只要把它带回来，我们就会给你——真的给你——尽可能多的钱。那是培训我的人告诉我的。
This is Jonathan Woodward. He worked at the LL Bean returns desk seasonally up until last year. He says the store used to give out cash for returns. Now it's store credit, but the principle is the same.
这是乔纳森·伍德沃德。他曾在LL Bean退货柜台做季节性工作，直到去年。他说商店以前退货是给现金。现在是商店积分，但原则是一样的。
Jonathan explained that the return policy is called, with reverence, the guarantee. And within the company, it's not so much policy as sacred foundational text. It's printed on every receipt and on the store's website. It reads, "our products are guaranteed to give 100% satisfaction in every way. Return anything purchased from us at any time if it proves otherwise."
乔纳森解释说，退货政策被称为“保证”，怀着敬畏之心。在公司内部，与其说是政策，不如说是神圣的基本准则。它印在每张收据和商店网站上。上面写着：“我们的产品保证在各方面给予100%的满意。如果有任何不符合要求，请在任何时间退回。”
Jonathan says, for him, behind the returns desk, the guarantee means not just that the customer is always right, not just that the customer is going to walk away satisfied that they're right, but also that they're going to walk away with--
乔纳森说，对他来说，在退货柜台后面，保证意味着不仅是顾客永远正确，不仅是顾客会带着他们是正确的满足感离开，而且他们还会带着——
As much money for whatever they bring in as you can possibly figure out how to do.
无论他们带什么来，你所能想出的尽可能多的钱。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah. It's the Magic Kingdom in flannel.
是的。这是法兰绒里的魔法王国。
LL Bean does sell a lot of flannel-- flannel sheets, flannel shirts, flannel pajamas. Also non-flannel-- fishing rods, mountain bikes, luggage, bathing suits, food, moccasins, watches, books, hunting rifles, sleds, furniture, canoes, socks. They sold a total of $1.6 billion worth of those things last year, all of which, of course, can be brought back.
LL Bean确实卖很多法兰绒——法兰绒床单、法兰绒衬衫、法兰绒睡衣。还有非法的——钓鱼竿、山地自行车、行李箱、泳衣、食物、莫卡辛鞋、手表、书、猎枪、雪橇、家具、独木舟、袜子。去年他们卖了总值16亿美元的这些东西，当然，所有这些都可以退回来。
And Jonathan says, at the returns desk, people are trained to keep their face and tone neutral, to not register any judgement whatsoever. Like when someone shows up at the front of the line wanting to return a half-eaten cookie. This actually happened to Jonathan once.
乔纳森说，在退货柜台，人们被训练保持面部和语气中立，不注册任何判断。就像有人排在前面想要退回一块吃了一半的饼干。这确实发生过在乔纳森身上一次。
You can't even look at them meaningfully when they're returning.
你甚至不能看着他们表达意义。
What do you read on their faces? Is it a certain kind of person who--
你在他们脸上读到了什么？这是一定的人吗——
No.
不。
It's anybody?
是任何人？
Oh, no. It's everybody.
哦，不。是所有人。
And here we are, Monday morning, the return area at LL Bean. Customers are pouring in. People are holding boots, fly rods, jackets, a pair of seersucker shorts, a Swiss army knife. One guy's carrying an entire Adirondack chair. Another has lugged in a bike rack.
我们现在是在周一早上，LL Bean的退货区。顾客蜂拥而至。人们拿着靴子、飞钓竿、夹克、一条泡泡纱短裤、一把瑞士军刀。一个人带着整把阿迪朗达克椅子。另一个人拖着一个自行车架。
There's one of those roped-off corrals that keeps people in line, and a long row of registers, where the customer service people stand, each one of them wearing a forest green shirt, each one of them looking cheerful and accommodating.
有一个用绳子围起来的畜栏让人们排队，还有一长排收款台，客户服务人员站在那里，每个人都穿着森林绿色的衬衫，每个人看起来都很愉快和乐于助人。
Your receipt has our guarantee on the back. And the survey is on the front. Thank you very much.
您的收据背面有我们的保证。正面有调查。非常感谢。
Thank you. Have a good day.
谢谢。祝你有美好的一天。
Congratulations--
恭喜——
A woman sets a pile of clothes on the return desk, including a v-neck T-shirt that she's just not into. It plunges too much.
一个女人在退货柜台上放了一堆衣服，包括一件她不喜欢的V领T恤。它领口开得太深了。
I don't do plunge. Our daughter does, but not me.
我不穿深V。我们的女儿穿，但我不是。
Seems like a legit return to me. The shirt was new. She got it home, regretted the purchase, and promptly brought it back.
对我来说这看起来像合法的退货。衬衫是新的。她带回家后后悔了购买，并立即带回来。
I spent hours hanging around the returns desk over the course of a couple of days, and I'd say that maybe 50% of the returns I saw were straightforward like this. But there were plenty that seemed to me questionable, if not outright crazy-- on part with the half-eaten cookie-- like a woman who showed up with a huge load of used twin-sized bedding. Seriously used bedding, I should say, because she'd upgraded to a queen bed. Is dissatisfaction the right word for this?
我在两天内花了几个小时在退货柜台闲逛，我会说我看到的大概50%的退货都是这样直截了当的。但有很多在我看来是有问题的，如果不说完全疯狂的话——和吃了一半的饼干差不多——比如一个女人带着一堆巨大的二手双人床品出现。我得说，是严重使用过的床品，因为她升级到了一张大床。不满是描述这个词吗？
Or the people who brought back a living room chair because they'd done a bad job strapping the chair to their car, so when it fell off and broke in the middle of a highway, they were upset. Or maybe they'd call it dissatisfied. They got store credit. They all did. Every one of these customers got store credit.
或者人们带回了一张客厅椅子，因为他们把椅子绑在车上没绑好，所以当它掉在高速公路中间坏掉时，他们很不高兴。或者他们可能会称之为不满。他们得到了商店积分。他们每个人都得到了。这些顾客中的每一个都得到了商店积分。
Then there was this guy, an older gentleman who patiently waited in line and then found himself in front of Cindy Wilson, one of the returns desk people. He pulled three extremely worn-out shirts-- two T-shirts and a chambray-- out of a paper bag.
然后有这个男人，一位年长的绅士耐心地排队，然后发现自己站在了辛迪·威尔逊前面，她是退货柜台的人员之一。他从纸袋里掏出了三件非常破旧的衬衫——两件T恤和一件钱布雷衬衫。
I love these. I wonder if they can be repaired. I've had them for years. They never wear out.
我爱这些。我不知道它们能不能修。我有它们好几年了。它们永远磨损不坏。
Oh, no, we can't repair them. What's wrong with them?
哦，不，我们不能修它们。它们怎么了？
He gestures at the shirt, saying something about how the stitching is coming apart around the armpits, though it's hard to see any specific wear and tear because the shirts just look generally worn and torn.
他指着衬衫，说了一些关于腋下缝线开裂的事情，尽管很难看到任何具体的磨损，因为这些衬衫看起来只是总体上磨损和撕裂了。
If you're not happy with them, we're happy to take them back for you.
如果您对它们不满意，我们很乐意为您退货。
Well, I've had them for years. I don't know.
嗯，我有它们好几年了。我不知道。
Well, it says satisfaction guarantee. We're going to leave that up to you, if you're satisfied or not.
嗯，上面写着满意保证。我们要把决定权留给你，看你是否满意。
Do something with them, he says.
处理一下它们吧，他说。
And how long do you think you've had them?
你认为你有它们多久了？
These I've had about 40 years.
这些我大概有40年了。
40 years?
40年？
That's me in the background blurting out, 40 years? Cindy doesn't blurt anything out.
那是我在后台脱口而出，40年？辛迪什么都没脱口而出。
Wow. Good for you. We'll get you a couple new ones.
哇。真为你高兴。我们给你换两件新的。
She issues store credit for the guy's shirts. $84.19, which has got to be more than he paid for them in 1976, so yay for inflation. In some ways, this is exactly the customer LL Bean wants-- loyal, loves the stuff.
她为那个人的衬衫发放了商店积分。84.19美元，这肯定比他在1976年支付的要多，所以通货膨胀万岁。从某些方面来说，这正是LL Bean想要的顾客——忠诚，热爱这些东西。
If he and his shirts embody a larger dilemma here, when it comes to the guarantee, there's a clear subtext-- or I think it's clear, anyway-- which is basically, be cool, everybody. Please, after 40 years, maybe you are satisfied. Maybe it's time to pay for a new shirt.
如果他和他的衬衫在这里体现了一个更大的困境，当谈到保证时，有一个清晰的潜台词——或者我觉得很清晰——这基本上是，大家都冷静点。拜托，40年之后，也许你是满意的。也许是时候为一件新衬衫付钱了。
I made my way backstage, right behind the returns desk, to a huge warehouse-like room. It's full of returned stuff in giant bins and plastic bags. Heaps and piles of them.
我去了后台，就在退货柜台后面，一个巨大的仓库般的房间。里面装满了放在巨大垃圾箱和塑料袋里的退货。堆积如山。
Shoes and tops, socks.
鞋子、上衣、袜子。
Cindy showed me around. She's been working in the returns department 25 years. She's a lifelong Mainer. Cheery, matter-of-fact.
辛迪带我参观了。她在退货部门工作了25年。她是土生土长的缅因人。开朗、务实。
She says one of the best things about working for Bean is the employee store, which is where some of the nicer stuff in the bins ends up. It gets sold to employees at a deep discount. $0.50 pants, $15 comforters. Cindy's house is full of other people's castoffs. Her towels have strangers' initials monogrammed on them. Her dog slept on a dog bed, also monogrammed with another dog's initials? Somebody's initials.
她说，为Bean工作的最好的事情之一就是员工商店，一些箱子里较好的东西最后会到那里。它以极大的折扣卖给员工。0.50美元的裤子，15美元的羽绒被。辛迪的房子里满是别人的废弃物。她的毛巾上有陌生人的名字缩写。她的狗睡在狗床上，也绣着另一只狗的名字缩写？某个人的名字缩写。
Dog collars.
狗项圈。
A dog collar? What would somebody say about the dog collar? Just didn't fit?
狗项圈？有人会对狗项圈说什么？只是不合适？
Well, I've heard stories from my dog died, so they no longer need the dog collar. It's their perception of the satisfaction guarantee.
嗯，我听说过关于我的狗死了的故事，所以他们不再需要狗项圈。这是他们对满意保证的理解。
I'm just going to say what Cindy won't say. It seems like some people are sort of renting stuff. But it's actually better than renting, like renting/borrowing almost.
我就直说辛迪不会说的话。看起来有些人是在某种程度上“租赁”东西。但它实际上比租赁更好，几乎像是租赁/借用。
There's a kind of seasonal ebb and flow to what people bring back. At the end of ski season, skis come back. When turkey hunting season is over, turkey hunting equipment comes back. Cindy had a story from the cash era, when the band Phish put on a three-day show in the tiny northern town of Limestone, Maine, and 60,000 people showed up for it.
人们带回的东西有一种季节性的起伏。滑雪季结束时，滑雪板会回来。土耳其狩猎季结束后，狩猎设备会回来。辛迪有一个从现金时代的故事，当时Phish乐队在缅因州北部一个叫利姆斯通的小镇举办了一场为期三天的演出，6万人参加。
When the Phish concert happened years ago, they would buy their equipment on the way to the concert, and when the concert ended, they returned all their equipment.
当Phish演唱会发生时，他们会在去演唱会的路上买设备，演出结束时，他们退回了所有的设备。
And you just gave out cash?
你们就发出了现金？
Yes, we gave out cash then. Yes.
是的，那时候我们发出现金。是的。
What kinds of stuff were people buying and returning?
人们在买什么又退什么？
Camping equipment. It was tents and stoves and sleeping bags. I don't know if you remember that concert, but it poured all weekend, so everything was soaking wet when it came back, and muddy.
露营设备。那是帐篷、炉子和睡袋。不知道你记不记得那场音乐会，但整个周末都在下雨，所以退回来的时候一切都湿透了，满是泥巴。
And your job was to just take it back and say thanks very much?
你的工作就是把它们收回来并说非常感谢？
If they said they weren't satisfied. Their tent didn't hold up in the rain and their sleeping bags got wet. They all had receipts, so there was no reason for us to say anything. It was all receipted returns.
如果他们说他们不满意的话。他们的帐篷没能挡雨，他们的睡袋湿了。他们都有收据，所以我们没有任何理由说什么。这全是带收据的退货。
Cindy says not everybody can hack it at the returns desk.
辛迪说并不是每个人都能在退货柜台干下去。
We try to gauge by personality who we want to bring in here because it does take a certain kind of person. People come in here and they do it for a week or two, and they just can't set their personal issues aside. So they just choose to go back to the sales floor. There are some people that have been here 30 years that will not come in here and do this.
我们试图通过个性来衡量我们想带谁进来，因为它确实需要某种人。人们进来这里工作一两周，他们就是不能把个人问题放在一边。所以他们选择回到销售楼层。有些在这里工作了30年的人，是不会进来这里做这个的。
Because?
因为？
It personally bothers them.
这从个人角度困扰他们。
It's difficult. It's a real mind-bending experience to just witness people coming in.
这很难。这是一种真正令人震撼的体验，亲眼见证人们进来。
Here's Jonathan again. Unlike Cindy and pretty much every other returns desk person I interviewed, he didn't hesitate to spell out exactly how it felt to stand before, say, a pair of used sheepskin slippers presented for return, not because the customer wasn't satisfied with them, but because the customer clearly loved them.
这是乔纳森。和辛迪以及我采访的几乎所有退货柜台人员不同，他不犹豫地准确地说明站在一双被提出退货的羊皮拖鞋面前是什么感觉，不是因为顾客对它们不满意，而是因为顾客显然很爱它们。
This isn't an isolated situation, by the way. There are masses of slippers piled up in the returns warehouse.
顺便说一句，这不是孤立的情况。退货仓库里堆满了拖鞋。
These truly disintegrating pieces of animal hide and fur that have been exposed to their feet for years and years and years of wandering around. The hide is all shiny. The shearling is totally mustard-colored and damp and matted. And it smells like four years of somebody's toes.
这些真正瓦解的动物皮毛，在被他们的脚暴露了几年又几年又几年之后。皮已经全亮了。剪羊毛全成了芥末色，又湿又粘。闻起来就像某人四年的脚趾味道。
[LAUGHING] OK. I get it. I get it.
[笑声]好的。我明白了。我明白了。
And they put them in front of you and they say, I want to return these. And there's no question you can ask that would-- there's no question, like don't you think that you might have gotten enough use out of these to warrant buying some new ones? I mean, Nikes fall apart in a year, but you don't even ask that. You just look at them, and your face is totally neutral, and their face is totally neutral, and you're going to both agree that the normal rules of retail interaction do not apply in this situation.
他们把它们放在你面前说，我想退回这些。没有任何问题你可以问，能够——没有任何问题，比如难道你不觉得你可能已经使用了足够长的时间，值得买一些新的了吗？我的意思是，耐克一年就散架了，但你甚至不问那个。你只是看着它们，你的脸完全中立，他们的脸完全中立，你们俩会同意正常的零售互动规则在这个情况下不适用。
Honestly, hearing what I heard, seeing what I saw, I wasn't sure who I felt upset with, the customers for their brazenness, or the company for just passively letting it all happen. LL Bean officials won't say how much the returns are costing them. They don't even try to estimate the ratio of legitimate returns to whoppers. Everyone I talked to there just kept saying, it's up to the customer. Customer makes the decision about what it means to be satisfied or not.
老实说，听到我听到的，看到我看到的，我不确定我更生谁的气，是生那些厚颜无耻的顾客的气，还是生这家公司只是被动地让一切发生的气。LL Bean官员不会说退货成本是多少。他们甚至不尝试估计合法退货与谎言的比率。我和他们谈过的每个人都只是不停地说，这取决于顾客。顾客自己决定什么是满意或不满意。
Here's what the company does now. The guarantee was not built for modern times. It came from one main shopkeeper, Leon Leonwood Bean, who sold mail-order hunting boots with a promise. If you weren't satisfied, you could return them. A century later, people are buying used LL Bean products in bulk on eBay and returning them for full price. Others scoop up piles of old parkas and shirts at thrift shops, stuff them into garbage bags, and bring them back for store credit. I talked to one guy who found an LL Bean jacket at Goodwill for $10 and returned it, triumphantly, for $360 in store credit.
这就是公司现在所做的。保证并不是为现代时代而建的。它来自一位主要的店主，莱昂·莱昂伍德·比恩，他卖带有邮购狩猎靴的承诺。如果你不满意，你可以退货。一个世纪后，人们在eBay上批量购买二手的LL Bean产品，并以全价退货。其他人从旧货店扫走一堆旧派克大衣和衬衫，把它们塞进垃圾袋，带回来换商店积分。我和一个人谈过，他在好时（Goodwill）以10美元找到了件LL Bean夹克，然后胜利地把它以360美元的商店积分退了回去。
I'm not saying this is a tragedy for the human race. I am saying that a hundred years ago, when the guarantee was born, the internet didn't exist. Thrifting was not a verb.
我不是说这是人类的悲剧。我是在说，一百年前，当保证诞生时，互联网不存在。旧货店买卖也不是动词。
The company tries, in its earnest flannel way, to push back. They've asked Goodwill stores to put a big, black X on the label of donated LL Bean clothes. Anything with an X on the label can't be returned. They've started asking for driver's licenses to keep track of a person's habits. If you're returning a lot but not buying a lot, you might get a polite cease and desist letter basically asking you to shop elsewhere.
公司尝试以一种真诚的法兰绒方式反击。他们要求好时商店在捐赠的LL Bean衣服标签上画一个大大的黑X。任何标签上有X的都不能退货。他们开始要求驾驶执照以追踪一个人的习惯。如果你退货很多但买得很少，你可能会收到一封礼貌的停止和终止信，基本上要求你在别处购物。
One woman on Twitter bragged recently about how she got some old boots for $8 at Goodwill and swapped them for a new pair at the store. She got a gentle reprimand tweet from LL Bean, signed LB. That's about as far as they'll go.
推特上的一位女士最近吹嘘她是如何在好时以8美元买了一些旧靴子，并在店里换了一双新的。她收到了LL Bean发来的轻柔谴责推文，署名是LB。这就是他们所能做的极限了。
I found out employees actually used to be allowed to inject just a tiny bit of judgment into their interactions with customers. They could, for example, say primly, that's not in the spirit of the guarantee. They could ask pointed follow-up questions or pause meaningfully before granting a return. That's what the employees I spoke with actually called it-- the meaningful pause.
我发现员工以前实际上被允许在与顾客互动中注入一点点判断。他们可以，比如规矩地说，这不符合保证的精神。他们可以问尖锐的后续问题或在准予退货前做出有意义的停顿。这就是我交谈过的员工实际上称呼它的名字——有意义的停顿。
There were even situations-- four of them-- where they could outright refuse a return. This is Bridget, who worked seasonally at LL Bean for several years.
甚至还有四种情况，他们可以直接拒绝退货。这是布里奇特，她曾在LL Bean做过几年的季节性工作。
Fire, death, divorce, weight loss.
火灾、死亡、离婚、减肥。
Meaning that if somebody came in and said, I lost 20 pounds and so I don't want my pants, you were supposed to say no?
意思是如果有人进来并说，我瘦了20磅，所以我不要我的裤子了，你应该说不？
Right. Yeah, we would say, well, I mean, it's 100% satisfaction guarantee. That actually-- that's not covered under it, those things.
对。是的，我们会说，嗯，我的意思是，这是100%满意保证。那实际上——那不在覆盖范围内，那些事情。
But LL Bean has let all those things go. Meaningful pauses are no longer allowed. Death, divorce, fire, and a killer dieting streak now officially count as situations that might, in fact, lead to dissatisfaction with your stuff.
但LL Bean已经放弃了所有这些。有意义的停顿不再被允许。死亡、离婚、火灾和致命的减肥记录现在正式算作可能导致你对东西不满的情况。
This move wasn't just to coddle customers. It was too hard on the staff to have to parse everyone's reasoning to make judgments about people all day long. Cindy, the returns veteran, says she sees her job more like being a bartender, listening to people's stories if they want to talk, giving them what they want, whether she thinks it's good for them or not.
此举不仅仅是为了宠坏顾客。让员工整天解析每个人的推理以对人做出判断太难了。退货老手辛迪说，她把自己的工作看得更像是当酒吧招待，如果他们想谈谈就听听人们的故事，给他们想要的，无论她认为这是否对他们好。
It's hard to be both a bartender and a moralist, especially because, yeah, she's seen people who are probably gaming the system, but she's also seen people who are probably just trying to get by. She's seen people bringing their old stuff back at Christmastime so they can afford presents for their kids. She said people tell her they're going to sell their store credit on eBay so they can get money to buy oil to heat their home. She said sometimes people bring in their dead spouse's clothing, saying it just makes them too sad having it around.
既做酒吧招待又做道德家很难，特别是因为，是的，她见过可能在操弄系统的人，但也见过可能只是在勉强维持生活的人。她见过人们在圣诞节时把旧东西带回来，这样他们就能为孩子们买礼物。她说人们告诉她他们打算在eBay上卖掉他们的商店积分，这样他们就能有钱买油来取暖。她说有时人们带来他们已故配偶的衣服，说放在周围让他们太难过了。
When I first approached LL Bean about doing this story, I thought they'd never agree to it, that they wouldn't want me talking about the guarantee on the radio at all, like I'd be offering some sort of playbook for the return policy maximizers of the world. But actually, they seemed to think the opposite. It's like they doubled down. Or maybe they're worried enough about the stretching of the guarantee that they want us all to be thinking more about our satisfaction.
当我第一次接触LL Bean做这个故事时，我以为他们永远不会同意，他们根本不想让我在广播中谈论这个保证，就像我在为世界上退货政策最大化者提供某种剧本。但实际上，他们似乎想到了相反的方向。就像他们孤注一掷了。或者也许他们足够担心保证的延伸，以至于他们想让我们所有人都更多地考虑我们的满意度。
There's been a debate recently inside the company about whether to change the guarantee, whether it's just too generous for the times we live in. But for now, they say, they will continue to accept people, and their stuff, and their lack of satisfaction, every day, as is.
公司内部最近一直在辩论是否要修改保证，是否对我们生活的时代来说太慷慨了。但目前为止，他们说，他们将每天继续接受人们，接受他们的东西，接受他们的不满，一如既往。
Sara Corbett is a writer in Portland, Maine.
萨拉·科比特是缅因州波特兰的作家。
I am not embarrassed to say on the radio that I read that book The Life-Changing Magic of Tidying Up , which, if you haven't read it, says you should go through everything you own one by one, ask yourself, looking at the object, does this bring me joy? And if it doesn't, get rid of it. Doesn't matter if you got a deal on it or you paid a lot of money because this is how you will feel the magic of being surrounded by the things that you love.
我不羞于在电台上说，我读过那本《怦然心动的人生整理魔法》，如果你没读过，它说你应该把你拥有的所有东西一件一件检查一遍，问自己，看着那个物体，这带给我快乐吗？如果不带给你，就把它扔掉。不管你买的时候是不是便宜货，或者是你付了很多钱，因为这就是你感受被你所爱的东西包围的魔法的方式。
I like this idea a lot, but what is that like for the object? The book does not talk about this. What is it like for the object to be constantly worried about whether or not you love it enough to keep it around you?
我非常喜欢这个想法，但对那个物体来说是什么感受？这本书没谈过这个。对一个物体来说，不断担心你是否足够爱它以至于留住它，是什么感觉？
This is Act Three, Make It Count. We finally hear from the voiceless object in a story from Simon Rich called "Unprotected." Heads up, this story acknowledges the existence of sex-- safe sex.
这是第三幕，算算账。我们终于从西蒙·里奇写的名为“未受保护”的故事中听到了无声物体的声音。注意，这个故事承认性行为的存在——安全性行为。
I born in factory. They put me in wrapper. They seal me in box. Three of us in box. In early days, they move us around. From factory to warehouse. From warehouse to truck. From truck to store.
我在工厂出生。他们把我放入包装纸。他们把我密封在盒子里。盒子里有我们三个。早些时候，他们把我们搬来搬去。从工厂到仓库。从仓库到卡车。从卡车到商店。
One day in store, boy human sees us on shelf. He grabs us, hides us under shirt. He rushes outside. He goes to house, runs into bedroom, locks door. He tears open box and takes me out. He puts me in wallet. I stay in wallet long, long time. This is story of my life inside wallet.
有一天在商店里，男人类在货架上看到了我们。他抓起我们，把我们藏在衬衫下。他冲到外面。他去了一个房子，跑进卧室，锁上门。他撕开盒子把我拿出来。他把我放进钱包。我在钱包里待了很久，很久。这是我在钱包里生活的生命故事。
The first friend I meet in wallet is Student ID Jordi Hirschfeld. He is card. He has been around longest, he says. He introduces me to other cards. I meet Provisional Driver's License Jordi Hirschfeld, Swimming Pool Access Card Jordi Hirschfeld, Jamba Juice Value Card, Business Card Albert Hirschfeld, DDS, Scarsdale Comic Book Explosion Discount Card
我在钱包里遇到的第一个朋友是学生证乔迪·赫什费尔德。他是一张卡。他说他是待得最久的。他把我介绍给其他卡。我见到了临时驾照乔迪·赫什费尔德、游泳池访问卡乔迪·赫什费尔德、赞巴果汁价值卡、名片艾伯特·赫什费尔德（牙医）、斯卡斯代尔漫画书爆炸折扣卡。
In middle of wallet, there live dollars. I am less close to them because they're always coming and going. But they are mostly nice. I meet many Ones and Fives, some Tens, a few Twenties. One time, I meet Hundred. He stayed for a long time. Came from birthday card, he said. Birthday card from an old person.
在钱包中间，住着美元。我和它们不那么亲近，因为它们总是来来去去。但它们大多是友好的。我遇到了很多1美元和5美元，一些10美元，几个20美元。有一次，我遇到了100美元。他待了很长时间。他说他来自生日卡。一位老人送的生日卡。
I also meet photograph of girl human, very beautiful, eyes like Swimming Pool Access Card. Blue, blue, blue.
我还遇到了女人的照片，非常漂亮，眼睛像游泳池访问卡。蓝，蓝，蓝。
When I first get to wallet, I am "new guy." But time passes. I stay for so long, I become veteran. When I first arrive, Jamba Juice has just two stamps. Next thing I know, he has fives stamps-- then six, then seven. When he gets 10 stamps, he is gone. One day, Provisional Driver's License disappears. In his place, there is new guy, Regular Driver's License. I become worried. Things are changing very fast.
当我第一次进钱包时，我是“新人”。但时间流逝。我待得太久，成了老兵。当我第一次到达时，赞巴果汁刚有两个印章。接下来我知道的是，他有五个印章——然后六个，然后七个。当他得到10个印章时，他就走了。有一天，临时驾照消失了。取而代之的是新人，正式驾照。我开始担心。事情变化得非常快。
Soon after, I am taken out of wallet. It is night. I am scared. I do not know what is happening. Then I see girl human. She is one from photograph. She looks same in real life, except now she wears no shirt. She is smiling, but when she sees me, she becomes angry. There is arguing. I go back inside wallet.
不久之后，我被带出了钱包。那是晚上。我很害怕。我不知道发生了什么。然后我看到了女人类。她就是照片里的那个。现实中看起来一样，只是现在她没穿衬衫。她在笑，但当她看到我时，她变得愤怒。有争吵。我回到了钱包里面。
A few days later, picture of girl human is gone.
几天后，女人的照片没了。
That summer, I meet two new friends. The first is Student ID New York University Jordi Hirschfeld. The second is. MetroCard. MetroCard is from New York City and he never lets you forget it. He has real "attitude." He is yellow and black, with Cirque du Soleil advertisement on back. When MetroCard meets GameStop PowerUp Card Jordi Hirschfeld, he looks at me and says, no wonder Jordi Hirschfeld not yet use you. I become confused. Use me for what?
那年夏天，我遇到了两个新朋友。第一个是纽约大学学生证乔迪·赫什费尔德。第二个是地铁卡。地铁卡来自纽约市，他永远不让你忘记这一点。他有真正的“态度”。他是黄黑相间的，背面有太阳剧团的广告。当地铁卡见到游戏驿站充值卡乔迪·赫什费尔德时，他看着我说，难怪乔迪·赫什费尔德还没用你。我变得困惑。用我做什么？
That night, MetroCard tells me many strange things about myself. At first, I do not believe what he says. But he insists all is true. When I start to panic, he laughs. He says, what did you think you were for? I am too embarrassed to admit truth, which is that I thought I was balloon.
那天晚上，地铁卡告诉了我许多关于我自己的奇怪事情。起初，我不相信他说的话。但他坚称一切都是真的。当我开始恐慌时，他笑了。他说，你以为你是干什么用的？我太尴尬以至于承认真相，那就是我以为我是气球。
It is around this time that we move. For more than two years, we had lived inside Velcro Batman. It is nice, comfy. One day, though, without warning, we are inside stiff brown leather. I am very upset-- especially when I see that so many friends are gone. No more GameStop PowerUp Card Jordi Hirschfeld. No more Swimming Pool Access Card Jordi Herschfeld. No more Scarsdale Comic Book Explosion Discount Card. Only survivors are MetroCard, Driver License, Student ID, myself, and a creepy new lady named Visa.
就在这个时候，我们搬家了。两年多来，我们一直住在维克罗蝙蝠侠里。那里很好，很舒服。不过有一天，毫无预警地，我们在坚硬的棕色皮革里。我非常不安——特别是当我看到这么多朋友不见了。不再有游戏驿站充值卡乔迪·赫什费尔德。不再有游泳池访问卡乔迪·赫什费尔德。不再有斯卡斯代尔漫画书爆炸折扣卡。唯一的幸存者是地铁卡、驾照、学生证、我自己，还有一位名叫维萨的令人毛骨悚然的新女士。
I am angry. What was wrong with Velcro Batman? It had many pockets and was warm. A few days later, I meet Film Forum Membership Jordan Hirschfeld. At this point, I am in "panic mode." What is "Film Forum"? Who is "Jordan Hirschfeld"?
我很愤怒。维克罗蝙蝠侠有什么问题？它有很多口袋，而且很暖和。几天后，我遇到了电影论坛会员卡乔丹·赫什费尔德。此时，我处于“恐慌模式”。什么是“电影论坛”？谁是“乔丹·赫什费尔德”？
Jordan Hirschfeld is same guy as Jordi Hirschfeld, MetroCard explains. He is just trying to "change his image." I am confused. What is wrong with old image? That night, I poke my head out of wallet and look around pocket. It is dark, but I can see we have new neighbor. He says his name is Cigarettes Gauloises. He is very polite, but I get weird vibe from him.
乔丹·赫什费尔德就是乔迪·赫什费尔德同一个人，地铁卡解释说。他只是在试图“改变他的形象”。我很困惑。旧形象有什么错？那天晚上，我把头探出钱包，环顾口袋。天很黑，但我能看到我们有新邻居。他说他的名字是高卢香烟。他很有礼貌，但我对他有一种奇怪的感觉。
It is about this time that I meet strip of notebook paper. On him is written [email protected] . Now we're getting somewhere, MetroCard says. I have never been more frightened in my life.
就在这时，我遇到了那条笔记本纸。上面写着[电子邮件受保护]。现在我们有了进展，地铁卡说。我一生中从来没有比这更害怕过。
That Saturday, five crisp Twenties show up. I assume they will stay long time, like most Twenties. But two hours later, they are gone, replaced by receipt La Cucina. MetroCard looks at receipt La Cucina and laughs. She better put out after that, he says. I am confused and worried.
那个星期六，五张崭新的20美元出现了。我以为它们会待很长时间，像大多数20美元那样。但两个小时后，它们不见了，被收据La Cucina取代。地铁卡看着收据La Cucina笑了。她最好在那之后付出代价，他说。我感到困惑和担忧。
Later on, I am minding my own business, when Jordi-- sorry, "Jordan" shoves his finger into me. I am terrified. What was that? I ask. MetroCard grins. He is checking to make sure you're there, he says. For later.
后来，我管我自己的事，这时乔迪——对不起，“乔丹”把他的手指塞进我里面。我很害怕。那是什么？我问。地铁卡咧嘴一笑。他正在确认你在那里，他说。为了以后。
My friends try to calm me down. One of the dollars, a One, tells me about the time he met Vending Machine Pepsi. He was stuffed in and out, in and out, so many times he almost died. I know he is trying to make me feel better, but I am like, please stop talking about that.
我的朋友们试图让我冷静下来。其中一个1美元，告诉我他见到自动售货机百事可乐的时间。他被塞进塞出，进进出出，那么多次，他差点死了。我知道他在试图让我感觉好点，但我说，请停止谈论那个。
Eventually, the moment comes. It is like other time. I am taken out of wallet and tossed on bed. It is very dark. I can make out shape of girl. She picks me up and squints at me for a while. Then she turns on lamp. I am confused. So is Jordan Hirschfeld.
最终，时刻到来了。就像另一次一样。我被带出钱包扔在床上。天很黑。我能辨认出女孩的形状。她拿起我眯着眼睛看了一会儿。然后她打开了灯。我很困惑。乔丹·赫什费尔德也一样。
"What's wrong?" he asks. His face is like Jamba Juice Value Card. Red, red, red.
“怎么了？”他问。他的脸像赞巴果汁价值卡。红，红，红。
"I think," she says, "that this might actually be expired."
“我想，”她说，“这个可能真的过期了。”
There is long silence. And then, all of a sudden, the humans are laughing! And then the girl is hitting Jordan with pillow! And he is hitting her back with pillow! And they are laughing, laughing, laughing. The girl reaches into her bag.
沉默了很久。然后，突然间，人类在笑！然后女孩在用枕头打乔丹！他也在用枕头打她！他们在笑，笑，笑。女孩伸手进她的包。
"Don't worry," she says. "I've got one."
“别担心，”她说。“我有一个。”
Part of me kind of wants to watch what happens next, but I'm quickly covered in pile of clothes.
我内心有点想看接下来发生什么，但我很快被一堆衣服覆盖。
When I wake up the next day, Jordan is dangling me over trash can. I look down into pit. Inside are Cigarettes Gauloises and Film Forum Schedule. They are talking "philosophy." I sigh. I do not really want to move in with them, but what can I do? I figure this is "end of the line" for me.
第二天我醒来时，乔丹正把我吊在垃圾桶上。我往坑里看。里面是高卢香烟和电影论坛日程表。他们在谈论“哲学”。我叹气。我真的不想和他们一起住，但我能做什么？我想这就是我的“终点线”。
Suddenly, though, Jordan carries me away-- to other side of room. I am placed inside shoebox under his bed. At first, I am afraid because it is dark, but as vision adjusts, I see I am not alone. There is strip of notebook paper [email protected] . There is receipt La Cucina, on which is now written, "First Date." I spend long, long time in shoebox.
然而，突然间，乔丹把我带走了——到房间的另一边。我被放进他床下的鞋盒里。起初，我很害怕，因为天很黑，但随着视力调整，我看到我并不孤单。有条笔记本纸[电子邮件受保护]。有张收据La Cucina，上面现在写着，“第一次约会”。我在鞋盒里待了很长，很长的时间。
When I arrive, I am new guy. But as time passes, I become veteran. I welcome many new friends-- Birthday card Rachel. Happy Valentine's Day Rachel. And many, many Post-it notes Rachel. Good morning, Jordi! Rachel. I love you, Jordi. Rachel. Everything in here is Rachel.
当我到达时，我是新人。但随着时间流逝，我成了老兵。我欢迎许多新朋友——生日卡瑞秋。情人节快乐瑞秋。还有许多许多便签纸瑞秋。早上好，乔迪！瑞秋。我爱你，乔迪。瑞秋。这里的一切都是瑞秋。
I do not know how things are in wallet these days, but I'm glad to be in shoebox. I feel as if I have "made it." I am happy. I am warm. I am safe.
我不知道现在的钱包里是什么样，但我很高兴待在鞋盒里。我觉得好像我已经“成功了”。我很快乐。我很温暖。我很安全。
This story came to us from Simon Rich, a frequent contributor to The New Yorker . It can be found in his collection Man Seeking Woman .
这个故事来自西蒙·里奇，他是《纽约客》的常客。可以在他的收藏集《男人寻找女人》中找到。
[MUSIC - "I'VE GOT FIVE DOLLARS AND IT'S SATURDAY NIGHT" BY FARON YOUNG]
[音乐 - 法伦·扬的“我有五美元，现在是星期六晚上”]
Our program was produced today by Karen Duffin and Chana Joffe-Walt. Our production staff, Sean Cole, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Lyra Smith, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike.
今天的节目由凯伦·达芬和查纳·乔夫-沃尔特制作。我们的制作人员，肖恩·科尔、伊曼纽尔·佐齐、尼尔·德鲁明、斯蒂芬妮·富、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普、莱拉·史密斯、马特·蒂尔尼和南希·厄普代克。
Other important people here, Elise Bergerson, Emily Condon, Kimberly Henderson, Seth Lind, and Julie Whitacre. Research help from Christopher Swetala. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
这里还有其他重要人物，埃莉斯·伯格森、艾米丽·康登、金伯利·亨德森、塞斯·林德和朱莉·惠特克。克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉的研究协助。达米安·格拉夫和罗布·格迪斯的音乐协助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to my boss, Ira Glass. He's been gone all week. We did get one message from him.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。本节目由PRX（公共广播交换中心）发送到公共广播电台。《美国生活》一如既往地感谢我的老板艾拉·格拉斯。他这一周都不在。我们确实收到了他的一条留言。
Things are just great. Things are really great. Things are really great. Things are really going good.
事情非常好。事情真的非常好。事情真的非常好。事情真的进展很顺利。
I'm Zoe Chace. Ira's back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是佐伊·蔡斯。艾拉下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。